so um one of our favorite departments on
this show is called 24 things you don't
know about me and we thought we would
bring it out this week because uh alex
jones is in the news you know he got uh
[Applause]
he uh he lost his little case there uh
and has to pay i think 45.2 million
dollars to the the sandy hook victim so
we thought this would be a good week to
bring out 24 things you don't know about
me
alex jones
like i oppose abortion because i like to
see suckers born every minute
[Laughter]
i've been anally penetrated by aliens so
many times i carry lube
[Applause]
my theory is that the diary of anne
frank is nothing more than a nasty
airbnb review
my go-to snack is onions and a handful
of unmarked medication
[Applause]
i have a line of camouflage that works
so well i can't find it anywhere
[Applause]
in high school i was voted most likely
to secede
[Laughter]
right
i believe the moon landing was real but
not landing was fake
not slandy
my drag queen name is misinformation
you